what
would be the evolutionary implications
of using masks
in the way we breathe and with regard to
our facial recognition system
[Music]
yeah um both of these are important um
well actually facial recognition i'll
say is clearly important
and i think i've said here before that
i'm i was super worried
especially when i saw young kids out um
when everyone was still masked um mostly
the very young kids i saw were not
masked although i saw exceptions to that
too
outside you know just so sad but um
but almost all the adults they were
seeing were masked
and those children were going through
some critical developmental period
um seeing only the people who they lived
with presumably unmasked and then the
occasional weirdo like me who'd walk by
unmasked and like i was just i was
getting
stares from these little children
outside in
in the era from like you know march of
last year through
yesterday practically when um i was
always masked inside in public spaces
with strangers but i was never masked
outside
and i was often the only one who wasn't
masked outside and these children would
just look at me
and it wasn't in horror it was in like
eagerness
is what i read in their eyes like oh my
god that's another one of us and
i want to see what it looks like um and
uh it's just devastating
for the children i'm sure it's
devastating and actually if we can step
back into a conversation it's in our
book
and we i think we've talked about it on
the podcast too um there's this one
tantalizing result from many years ago
in which there was a question about
whether or not
autism was triggered by screen time
and the way i've interpreted that result
and the way we discuss it in the book
is that the thing about a screen
especially um i think we talk about
cartoons
uh in the book but a screen that is
capable of projecting the image of a
human being
that's very compelling looking and or
humanoid
right a humanoid yeah but that does not
respond
right to humans who sit right exchange a
lot of information that isn't
vocal right there's a lot of facial
expression stuff that indicates stuff
that we can't even prevent
right about emotional state and things
like that so for a child
learning to do that game learning to
exchange information
emotionally a screen is a very
paradoxical entity because it broadcasts
the information
but it's it's read only and so
there's question about if masks are
going to have some of this influence too
where
the emotions are literally masked so the
children
who are developing their capacity to
read them are not getting nearly as much
information
i do think i mean it's it's different i
don't know better or worse but it's
different than say
you know a cartoon that has the
expressions but is never responsive to
the actual child watching
um which is that there's just an absence
of information so is you know
is pure absence without the possibility
for a misfire
on signal worse or is
um you know seeing emotional things
seeing the full gamut-ish
of emotional possibilities but having
them applied at random relative to
your the engager um engagement with them
worse i think actually that's probably
still worse well
it's a really interesting question i
could see it going either way i think
it's a very important question
i would add one other thing though like
i'm now because masks outside are so
pointless
yeah um i'm beginning to see them as
more metaphorical
and they're frightening right in the
sense that lots of
humans are you know not broadcasting
uh these signals that are so much a part
of
functioning yeah and one thing i'm
beginning to wonder about
is i'm also watching other things happen
that
we're true long before the mask thing
happens so i know the masks aren't
causal but i think they're consistent
with which is
10 years ago right there was a way of
broadcasting to a stranger
that you were not a threat right there
was a way of signaling that this is a
friendly infra
interaction and you don't need to worry
right and this was a normal part of
walking down the god damn street and
there were cities in which it wasn't
in which people did not exchange any
sort of
smile or whatever as they passed and
those places were always jarring
but in much of the world it was just
simply expected that you would
signal even just signaling anything and
not having anger or frustration or
tension in your voice
would let somebody breathe easier and or
blankness
right what i get now and i hate this as
a man i
hate it right anytime
i am in the world and i encounter a
woman i don't know walking the other
side of the street in the elevator
whatever it is there's this question
about whether or not i'm a menace now i
understand that that's
a natural question but it used to be
something for which the tools to dispel
the question
were readily available and i don't find
them
readily available at all if you're asked
not even that because there's the
averting of the eyes
oh yeah right so it's like the point is
the channel is not even open and
actually
i had this experience uh it was so
bewildering okay
i was in this hotel in austin and it's
one of these hotels that you need to use
your key card to
ride in the elevator and
i got in the elevator a woman had just
gotten in the elevator
before me right she used her card
and then she hit the same floor as i was
going to so there was no need for me to
hit
the any button i didn't need to use my
card so she didn't know whether i was
legitimately in the elevator or not
right because i was traveling to her
floor there was no
good way of signaling i'm not a creep
this is just a coincidence that i'm
going to your floor
right i literally did not know what to
do because the entire ride in the
elevator
was just full of this tension like you
just got in the elevator
i know you need a key card to use this
elevator you didn't pull out your key
card and i was like
i was just helpless there was nothing i
could do to let her know
that this you know and so i actually
just let her get out of the elevator
and i stayed in the elevator bank until
she had long gotten into her room so she
wouldn't find me following her down the
hall but it's like
what kind of world are we living in that
you can't signal to a stranger hey
don't worry that's terrible um
elevators are always potentially fraught
this way or like i mean especially
elevators in hotels and
and women traveling alone you know it's
there's there's always been an issue and
i'm not sure
i'm not sure what it you know 10 years
ago
you could have communicated that would
have um i mean
i guess you could have just i could have
just said something but not now
it's so fraught that the point is
because a bad
person will lie and so the information
isn't contained in what's said it's
contained in the fact that it's
disarming in the way you say it
right now the tension is so high that
the attempt to disarm
is like an attempt to disarm and that's
frightening and it's like
can we please just go back to a place
where
we don't you know we don't take it on
faith that somebody else is safe to
interact with but that is our bias
right somebody is safe until they do
something that suggests they are not
yeah and you leave open the possibility
of totally trivial conversation a
conversation
about the [ __ ] weather would have
been useful in this case yeah no i mean
i think that's right i mean this is
there's not going to be a universal
answer and you know if you've got like
trust everyone and trust no one right um
we're most of us are going to fall
somewhere in here
right and the which one was which trust
everyone trust no one
thought just reverse it trust everyone
trust no one um
and the sort of the we're told
and we were informed in part by like the
metoo movement and such
that this slider has to move over here
that we have to trust everyone less
and they're you know i think
women in general as is should be
expected we'll
we'll we'll be reading the world
differently because the threats are
different
and frankly a hotel a hotel elevator is
a particularly
fraught and potentially dangerous
environment and
um at some level
you know she pressed that button while
you're already in the elevator
that's kind of a signal um that either
she's not reading the situation at all
or she's kind of looked at you and been
like not a threat
because in general a lone woman
a lone man an elevator a woman doesn't
press the floor first
like you don't signal where it is where
it is that you're going to
you know almost no matter what and like
that's just that that's an unfortunate
part about
being you know a woman being alone in
the world at that moment
i didn't know that yeah and i get it
yeah i get it and i've heard
i've heard women say um you know
apparently some men were confused by why
a woman wouldn't walk away from her
drink at the bar
and some woman said how are you missing
this i was like holy crap i've never
heard that
um but of course i mean this is what me
too was supposed to do right right like
like and frank like you and i have been
together forever and
some of the stuff that even even between
us like
it's just like of course and like
you should fill that in i haven't i
don't know what you're saying yet well
no i mean like the elevator thing and
the drink at the bar
you would think that's obvious to me but
it's not yeah yeah and
you know this is exactly what me too was
supposed to do yeah it's exactly what it
was supposed to do and it got hijacked
and maybe it started out hijacked like
maybe blm started out hijacked
and it just had the good sounding stuff
like i i don't actually
have the sense of what the thing behind
me two was but it had the potential
to exactly inform the vast majority of
men who are awesome
and who couldn't frickin you know follow
a woman to her
hotel room and hurt her for you know for
anything they just wouldn't
but inform them of what it is actually
to walk around going like actually i'm
paying attention
i'm not going to put that information
into that guy's head because i don't
know who that guy is okay
i'm not going to inform him of what
floor i'm going right but yeah okay so i
know this is perfectly consistent with
what you just said it's not a
counterpoint but yeah um
the greatest asset to women in a world
where most
men are not bad but bad men are common
enough that you have to constantly be on
your guard
let me just rephrase that for a second
sorry the way that i've said that is the
vast majority of men aren't bad but the
vast majority of women have interacted
with a bad bad man yes
yeah the best asset in that case
is all of those men who aren't bad out
there
right and their ability to uh
participate
in a social agreement that women need to
be protected from those rare
bad men right cutting off the line of
communication so that i cannot write it
i mean
believe me if anybody has the skills to
to
signal that i am not a threat in a
freaking elevator i've got those skills
in spades i couldn't figure out how to
do it in this case
yeah now many days later i know what i
should have done
it would have been a flat out lie i
should have taken my key card out
i should have used it on the elevator
and i should have pressed
a floor somewhere else that's what i
actually as you were telling the story i
was like well this is what he's going to
do right
that didn't occur to me at the time yeah
so it absolutely and so
unless if i had been that woman in that
elevator and it never met you and didn't
know you on site or something right like
um you know you're a totally anonymous
random dude in a hotel
like hey it's in a hotel so it's not
just a
you know a random high-rise in a city
where anyone can walk in so it's a
little bit more protected
and it's possible you know there's
definitely been situations so i just
like oh you know he's fine like
this guy's no problem at all but in
general i wouldn't have put the
information
into your head where i'm going um but
if i had not um or if you know if you
and i don't know you're trying to be a
gentleman or you're trying to get the
information oh after you
after you miss ma'am whatever it is they
might come
um i'd put in the wrong floor like if if
someone invites me to give them
information that i've already decided i
don't want to give them i'm going to
give them bad information well it's
actually
so i'm trying to remember exactly what
happened yeah we're spending a lot of
time here but i sort of think it's worth
it
yeah um so it happened to be
the top floor that that elevator went to
right that's where i was and that's the
floor that she pressed was there also
public stuff on that floor then like a
restaurant or a gym or something
just rooms um now it's possible
if i were in her shoes and i didn't
trust that i just gotten into an
elevator with some guy who in this
case could have just walked in off the
street there was no bar to getting in
this elevator the bar was the key card
to your ability to go to a floor
right so if i was her and i was being
clever i might have pressed the top
floor with the thought he has to get out
of the elevator somewhere before
that floor right um
in any case i don't think that can be
right because i think she
i as i said i waited in the elevator
bank until she had cleared the hallway
i guess she could have gone into the
stairs and gone down or she
went into a room which is what i think
she did but
nonetheless the point is what kind of
crazy world are we living in
where somebody who means you no harm
can't simply
broadcast that information and then you
can evaluate it you don't have to
believe it well
so know the different thresholds that
that women will have you know and and
then we'll just engage this differently
because the kinds of things that will
bad things that will happen to be to men
will be a different a different set of
of horrible things um
the the threshold that we choose
individually as
as women is going to be based on a
number of things our
personal experience and our um
you know our capacity our imagined
capacity for reading someone and for you
know spending just a half second going
like oh
yeah i think he's fine um and i think
that thing
that sort of i'm actually gonna look and
engage and do the assessment
that's part of what is just like being
flattened
and so if we're not expecting people
we're not
but we're not expecting people and
people aren't learning how to do that
sort of assessment and
you know again you know a year and a
half of covet and social isolation and
masks and
like we got that problem in spades now
um
then i would guess that there would be
yes less and less opportunity
um and to to actually for you
as a man to engage with a woman who
might be a little like i don't know what
he's what he's doing
um but you know the other thing that is
true
is that you know from forever not just
in this modern environment
um the best intentioned most awesome man
who just wants to be gracious and signal
that he's not a threat and so you know
can't we just be human together
uh mesa may still set someone's spidey's
senses off and you know what if she
gives you misinformation if she wants to
have nothing
like you know this unless
if it's a you know if it's an elevator
ride like if it's something that it
doesn't have any reason to
extend um you know be a little irritated
that she didn't see the awesome that you
were but like
let her go and do it somebody's nervous
they have
the right to do what they have to do in
order to get out of the situation
feel as safe as they can as quick as
they can i don't i'm not saying she
doesn't have a right to
whatever tool she needs to get to there
my point is
how did we end up where the total
toolkit for
navigating these things and and
diffusing them isn't available to us and
i actually think it goes to a point that
you were making
last week right about the
binariness of the choices that we are
given
right in a world where either you do or
do not believe that all men are toxic
right then you have no way to learn this
and i guess my point would be there's an
intermediate to the guy who's really
dangerous
in the elevator me not dangerous at all
no threat of any kind there's an
intermediate right yeah there's a guy
who's interested
but he's not a threat right and so my
point is a woman who
is able to practice learning you know
whether somebody is threatening
isn't threatening or is somewhere in
between right is interested but is not
going to push the matter right that's a
once you've
seen the spectrum of reactions then you
can begin to get good at recognizing
whether somebody is in one category the
other or somewhere in the middle and
you'll be better not only at avoiding
danger and harm and risk to yourself but
also
more likely to actually end up with
interactions and possibly relationships
and enrich your life
right right so in some sense what i'm
perceiving is driving me crazy because
basically the point is well until i know
until i have
evidence that you're not a threat i'm
simply going to
not only treat you as one but assume
that you are one
right um that is a manifestation of a
very broken developmental process where
women don't get a chance to
figure out how to sort the vast majority
of men who are not
a threat from the few that are who are
way too common to be ignored and the
larger number
included in that first category as you
say who um are not a threat but are
you know maybe interested in pushing
their luck a little bit to see if maybe
she really is interested
right and you know some women will be
sometimes interested in playing that
game and a lot of them would be like
could you please leave me the [ __ ] alone
right right
but nonetheless on on both sides of that
interaction yeah there is learning to be
done yeah if we go around
you know prosecuting every man right who
pushes his luck just a tiny bit too far
then nobody you know the men don't learn
right
yeah no one learns right yeah we're just
we go backwards yeah
yeah cool that was an unexpected
answer to a question about masks right
so
yes let that be a lesson to you don't
wear your mask outside and
i don't know look people in the eye
enough to figure out whether
they seem menacing indeed
[Music]
you